2014 Rawad arrive en France pour une
nouvelle vie le jeune étudiant veut
travailler et apprendre le français il
enchaîne les CDD il en cumule 2 et se
voit refuser la nationalité française au
motifs qu'il travaille trop
tu fais la demande de la demande
nationalité je travaille Leclerc Leclerc
et je travaille
distributeur de publicité avec des
courriers la même temps je travaille
comme ça de pendant trois ans de boulot
ensemble après après la demande
j'ai surprise les refuser un rapport
parce que je travaille trop
depuis Rawad a fait appel et il a eu
gain de cause aujourd'hui c'est un
deuxième départ pour lui il vient
d'ouvrir son restaurant très fier de
faire découvrir son pays sa culture et
sa ville Alep le célèbre c'est
ça c'est spécialité de la ville de Alep
c'est à base extérieur
c'est filé de poulet avec Bourgogne et
intérieur on a forcé de viande hachée
amande et oignons en quelques jours les
saveurs de Damas font le plaisir des
papilles berruguières
c'est une très belle ville c'est de
l'histoire
et voilà on aime beaucoup et on les aime
et ça nous fait plaisir que sur la terre
en France qui font des des délices de
Damas vraiment ça nous fait plaisir
salut
je connais pas la Syrie mais c'est qu'il
fait un c'est qu'ils font là c'est qui
sont attirants et puis c'est bon pour
nous aussi
de travailler il veut ouvrir sa chaîne
de restaurant et surtout offrir une
belle vie à sa fille Tasnim